[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre pays est toujours ouvert un
dialogue direct et honnête pour trouver
des solutions diplomatiques
les intérêts et la sécurité de nos
citoyens à 100 pour nous non négociable
pedroni ses déclarations publiques comme
privées des derniers jours il déchire
les accords de minsk qu'il avait
lui-même signé piétine délibérément le
droit international et les traités
signés depuis des années par la russie
on doit condamner absolument fermement
et mettre en place des sanctions qu'ils
soient des sanctions vraiment puissante
pour éviter l' escalade de ce conflit et
dire à vladimir poutine maintenant c'est
stop il y a un an un graphiste russe
faisait défiler les troupes de dark
vador dans saint pétersbourg pour
pointer du doigt l'autoritarisme de
vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui avec la crise en ukraine ces
montages vidéo ressurgissent notamment
celui ci
sur la place rouge à moscou n'a donc
maintenant les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens ils arrêtent de
jouer solo ils s'affichent ensemble ils
prennent des sanctions ensemble et ils
vont ensemble à kiev pour défendre la
démocratie et l'intégrité du territoire
je vais commencer à imposer des
sanctions bien au delà des mesures que
nous et nos alliés avons appliquée en
il est encore temps d'éviter le scénario
du pire qui infligera d'énormes
souffrances à des millions de personnes
l'invasion russe les troupes de poutine
au porte de kiev le scénario du pire est
envisagée alors la population se tient
prête certains se disent même à prendre
les armes pour défendre leur pays ce
sont des sanctions très forte et
sanctions très lourdes qui visent des
responsables russes compris les membres
de l'entourage du président russe les
ukrainiens qui ont acheté une arme ces
dernières semaines se voit offrir une
pizza un moyen étonnant de pousser la
population à se défendre face à poutine
malheureusement ni la france ni hat ne
pesant beaucoup de sa malheureuse en un
faire valoir parce qu'il sait qu'il ya
des élections en face et que ça ça
résonne dans le monde entier nous nous
réservons de infligé à la russie des
sanctions beaucoup plus pénalisante si
jamais valdimir poutine persistait dans
sa politique de violation du droit
international
nous y travaillons on parle de sanctions
ce sont des sanctions complètement
illégal les seules sanctions valable
commerce international et puisqu'on se
prévaut de respecter les règles l'été
les règles de droits à l'international
ce sont les sanctions qui sont décidées
par l'onu là il s'agit de manière de cow
boy c'est à dire qu'on copie les
américains la russie à la force des
états faibles c'est-à-dire des états qui
vous menace et qu'ils ont un pouvoir de
nuisance les véritables pouvoirs de la
russie de vladimir poutine soyez pouvoir
de nuisance nuisances militaire et
nuisances énergétique la parfumerie un
secteur d'activité qui exportent vers la
russie mais aussi l'aéronautique ou la
pharmacie
au total l'an dernier la france a
exporté pour 6,4 milliards d'euros soit
1,3 pour cent de ses exportations
totales pour le reste ce n'est pas un
état économique majeur pour la france
donc l'impact sera limité mais il ya
aussi des entreprises installées en
russie 700 filiale des pme mais aussi
des gros groupes comme décathlon danone
la société générale ou auchan
l'entreprise renault est cool elle trois
cent mille de ces véhicules chaque année
dans le pays
c'est la facture d'électricité et de gaz
des français qui va y qui va très très
vite augmenter c'est le prix à la pompe
le baril va dépasser très largement les
champs de la hoya alerte rouge c'est à
dire que pour la première fois la
situation marine le pen mais aussi
probablement celle de jean-luc mélenchon
et d'eric zemmour va peut-être aboutir
un scandale démocratique
si on ne veut pas jeter nous élus en
pâture il faut les protéger
cette protection c'est nécessairement
l'anonymat